bonjour nous glacialis merci d'être
matinale et de répondre à nos questions
très tôt ce matin sur rtl france
selon joe biden des violences par armes
à feu représente une épidémie ce terme
épidémie est ce qu'il est pas mal venu
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale provocation selon vous ou
véritable constat un appel des deux
côtés c'est rien du tout mais comme il y
en 100 m des gens ils sont tués quand
les à chaque jour aux états unis
il y en demi million des crimes commis à
10 ans aux états unis donc été démis
c'est c'est du rétro mais il y avait un
gros ce problème culturel commercial et
réglementaire avec les états unis et il
va vers la solution à double assiette
deux massacres commis le mois dernier
aux états unis des fusillades en géorgie
et dans le colorado qui ont donc
contraint le président américain passer
à l'action
joe biden a dévoilé un des premières
mesures pour mieux encadrer le marché
des armes à feu qu'est ce que vous
retenez des dispositions avancées on le
repère un plus de quarante mille
personnes meurent sous les balles des
armes à feu chaque année aux états unis
we are the story of notre ministère de
justice
donc ils n'abordent pas pour l'instant
de législation des lois ce temps des
choses comme indication des hommes en
vous sur les fameuses ghost gagnent les
hommes fantômes qui sont vendus en kit
sans même un numéro et chiffres il veut
rétablir loi qu'il a passées en 94 pour
interdire les armes d'assaut
c'était maintenant aux lois non
fonctionnaires livre le ranger faut dire
il veut avoir un fichier national donné
un milliard de dollars aux communautés
donc
c'est de faire ici et là les petites
choses mais l'essentiel c'est qu'il ne
contrôle pas le sénat et 160 voire il
courait pas avoir une loi passée au vote
final dans le cénacle et me tuer comme
en hausse oppose justement quelles sont
les chances que le plan de joe biden
abouti ce qu il sait qu'il n'est pas en
position de faire adopter ce qu'il veut
sur ce sujet ultra sensible en raison de
la très courte majorité parlementaire
démocrate vaut au congrès oui à tj coach
culture dans laquelle les hommes à feu
sont une politique très important pour
le droite donc s'opposer à leurs armes à
feu pouvaient être joués dans l'âme il
ya comment s'opposer au droit
constitutionnel des américaines de
posséder un
en plus il ya un puissant lobby de
manufacture des sommes qu'ils ont
achetée en gros ce nombre de sénateurs
et de députés et donc ça ne va pas
aboutir dans une loi même on essaie
programme c'est de nommer un directeur
imminente des agences de réglementation
des hommes ce qu'apple encore on exige
encore une affirmation par le sénat et
mitch mcconnell a promis un graphe parce
qu'il veut pas que le pouvoir ce n'est
trop real de ralentir militantes réglant
tire les législations soit en l'aider et
à protéger ses doigts considère l
éthique on va s'opposer à beaucoup de
programmes substantielle vous ne parlez
du lobby 1
quel rôle exactement jouent le puissant
lobby des armes à feu aux états unis on
pense forcément à la nra national rifle
association qui représente ce marché
outre atlantique
oui vous avez bien cibler la haine et
donc ils jouent un jeu entre
le centre de washington en paix les
fondent pour les campagnes électorales
c'est une grosse donateurs des ans des
millions et des millions de dollars pour
acheter des députés mais en plus ils
n'ont pas pu visiter l'opinion publique
avec les publicités avec le cndd
association avec le plus de membres aux
états unis donc les manufactures de en
joual antérieure de washington avec le
système de login et à l'extérieur de
washington avec une campagne de
propagande pour que les gens en sont
plus sûres avec des armes à feu dans ma
maison
merci douglas y est c'est d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de droit et
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines